now for the seventh year in a row
countries around the world have spent
record sums of money on weapons even
before russia's war in ukraine started
that's according to the stockholm
international peace research institute
total global military expenditures for
the first time exceeded 2 trillion
dollars
last year an increase of 0.7 from the
year before the biggest spenders were
the united states china india the uk
russia
france
as you see it there india
as well and germany
now together they account for about
two-thirds of global military
expenditure china's military spending
grew for the 27th consecutive year
and with many countries propping up
their defense amid russia's invasion of
ukraine military expenditures are likely
to rise further that's why i asked
alexandre marsteiner of the stockholm
international peace research institute
if we were in the middle of a new global
arms race
it's always a bit difficult to judge
based on on just the numbers but we are
seeing a new record high in global
military expenditure uh 2021 uh in 2021
we've reached over 2.1 trillion us
dollars
whether or not that counts as an arms
race is a matter of perspective but we
we're definitely observing a
continuous increasing trend
what is your forecast for the coming
years uh how will the
uh
war in ukraine boost military
expenditure so uh shortly after russia
launched its invasion against ukraine
you know there were being announcements
made every every couple of hours that
governments intended to further increase
military spending you know we saw that
in germany we saw it in sweden romania
poland
there's also a good chance that the u.s
congress will further boost um spending
beyond what the fight administration had
requested
so you know
we see that this trend will probably uh
continue for for some time
now obviously uh you are with a peace
research uh institution but amid
russia's aggression in ukraine and fears
of neighboring countries that moscow
wants to reach even further
isn't increased military spending a good
thing at this point of time
well i think you know everyone kind of
has to decide that for themselves uh on
the one hand you know it's true that the
the russian invasion of ukraine really
uh did shatter the european security
order um threat perceptions are now at
an all-time high i i would think it's
understandable
um that many people are calling for
increased military spending but on the
other hand you know you always have to
consider every money being spent on the
military is uh is you know a dollar or a
euro
that's not being spent on education
health care social programs economic
relief and and that sort of spending so
that's up to every country for itself
that is that is a given if a country ups
its military spending the money is
lacking elsewhere
well i mean it also depends on how how
the funding is is financed right you
know governments can raise taxes uh they
can take out loans they can they can
make cuts elsewhere but in principle you
know we talk about a trade-off between
military spending and other types of
spending
alexandra do higher military
expenditures immediately mean more guns
and rockets i mean where exactly is the
money going
so military spending doesn't
automatically mean procurement spending
right there are other types of spending
you need to pay the salaries of troops
you need to
buy fuel for your tanks
so you know
procurement is only a part of it but we
are seeing that many of these announced
increases are very much focused on on
military procurement as well as research
and development
alexander marksteiner of the stockholm
international peace research institute
thank you for your time
thank you